our bodies are great at losing heat and
our clothes are great at keeping heat in
now researchers have made a textile that
for the first time keeps skin cool using
already existing materials the history
of clothing technology has been all
about keeping us warm fur feathers and
wool all holed pockets of warm air next
to the skin cooling is a bigger
challenge high-tech wicking technology
does cool you but only once you start
sweating this new approach is passive no
pumps or fans needed and it doesn't make
you wait for the sweat to begin working
bodies lose heat through infrared or
thermal radiation these waves are
usually blocked or reflected by clothes
some materials like plastic film he'll
love these waves through the catch they
also let invisible light clearly not
suitable for clothing but using the
common plastic polyethylene engineers
may have figured out a way to make it
work they found that plastic with
certain sized pores allows thermal
radiation to pass through but the pores
scatter visible light giving the
material a solid light appearance the
textile is more efficient at greedy
heating heat than cotton in fact it can
keep fake skin about 2.7 degrees cooler
in lab tests this might seem like a
small amount but little numbers can make
a big difference only a few degrees
change in a building's temperature for
example can save forty five percent of
the energy needed for cooling so now you
can lose the heat without losing your
shirt
you